excuse me where you going
we're cutting the budget in half yes how
are you what would you like today
can I get something else
yes indeed
so far so good okay no I'm not
suggesting we all carry around these
silly little signs but learning how to
communicate digitally with emoji is a
must
here are my three tips for learning this
crazy new language number one bring up
your emoji keyboard and familiarize
yourself with the lingo study the emojis
on your phone so you know which chicken
to pick there are five and we're to find
that wind chime that best expresses your
feelings number two understand that
these characters are best for expressing
emotions fun reactions to things and
quick responses like yes and no number
three get a good emoji keyboard
especially on the iPhone this will let
you more easily find the emojis you want
I like emoji plus plus on the iPhone but
I really love kemo G which translates
your text to emoji for you on Android
there aren't that many great options but
I do like Swift key
I think there's a Starbucks over that
way hey guys look like it